Tim Ferriss: Hello, boys and girls, ladies and
germs. This is Tim Ferriss. Welcome to another
episode of The Tim Ferriss Show, where it is
my job to deconstruct world class performers
from all different walks of life, all different
arenas, to tease out the habits, lessons learned,
et cetera, that you can apply to your own lives.
My guest today, long overdue, is Mark Manson. You
can find him all over the webs, including
on Twitter @IAmMarkManson. Mark is a three
time number-one New York Times bestselling
author of The Subtle Art of Not Giving a Fuck,
maybe you've heard of it as well as other titles.
His books have sold nearly two zero, 20 million
copies worldwide, and have reached number one in
more than a dozen countries. Since 2008, he has
written articles at MarkManson.net, one of the
largest personal development blogs in the world,
with more than a million monthly readers. In
2023, a feature film about him and his work
will be released in theaters by Universal
Pictures. We'll link to everything in the
show notes as per usual at tim.blog/podcast.
Mark, welcome to the show. Nice to see you.
Mark Manson: It's a pleasure. Happy to be here.
Tim Ferriss: I read this profile of you in New
York Mag, and it shared many different stories and
I want to dig into maybe certain aspects of that.
But what I'd be curious to hear, just off the
cuff, because a lot has happened in your life
in the last five to seven years, what have
been some of the most difficult changes to
get accustomed to or default behaviors to
modify now that your reality has changed?
Mark Manson: I feel like we could do the
entire show just on this. You could do
probably do an entire episode. Maybe you
could get an all-star guest list of what
people don't tell you about success.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, let's do it.
Mark Manson: So one thing, the most surprising
thing and the most difficult thing at the same
time was The Subtle Art of not Giving a Fuck, came
out in 2016, it hit number one early 2017. And by
mid 2017 it was just off to the races. I think it
sold two or three million copies just that year.
And for me, it was very strange. I mean obviously
there was a lot of happiness and joy, but for me,
it was very strange, because as a young author
with their first traditionally published book,
I had all of these long-term goals and dreams
and visions for myself of I'm going to be
writing till I'm 50, and maybe one day I'll be
on the Times list and maybe one day I'll get
invited on a morning show. And I hit all
those dreams in three months, basically.
And so my surprise is that there was
just this profound kind of emptiness
on the other side of that, of, "Oh, what do I
dream now? What do I hope for in my future?"
And so very unexpectedly, I spiraled into a little
bit of a funk, a little bit of a depression. And
the worst thing about that type of depression
is nobody wants to hear you talk about it.
Tim Ferriss: There's no tears shed.
Mark Manson: Yes, no sympathy whatsoever.
Like, "Oh, boohoo, poor author, sold
three million books," or whatever. And
so it really caught me off guard. And there was a
little bit, there was imposter syndrome, which I
think comes with any sort of monumental success.
There was a little bit of what do I do now?
How do I follow this up? A lot of insecurity of
am I ever going to do anything this meaningful
or noteworthy again? And I struggled with
that for a number of years, and that was
just on the emotional and personal side. That
doesn't even get into relationships and money.
I feel like it's almost like a prerequisite
to being "wealthy" is you have to spend money
on something stupid that you regret. I just feel
like that is a non-negotiable. You're not really
wealthy until you've done that at some point.
So I went through a couple of those experiences.
Tim Ferriss: What would be the most notable?
Mark Manson: A fucking house.
The funny thing about me is I'm very
minimalist. I'm very Spartan. I don't really
like to have a lot of possessions, but for
some reason when it was time to buy a house,
I'm like, "You know what? Let's just get all
the rooms. I have nothing to put in them,
but let's get them all." And that
was just an unbelievable mistake that
really made my life a headache for a while.
Tim Ferriss: What are some of the things — and
just so people listening understand where I'm
probably going with this, there is a meandering
path, but there is a path, is I want to talk
about the present tense and then I'm going to
rewind and do, I don't want to call it a life
review, but look at some of the trajectory at
least insofar as I've been able to observe it in
the course of watching you do what you've done
from the sidelines, but also having done research
for the conversation. So present tense though,
building on what we were just talking about. What
are some of the things you thought you wanted
or needed that you got and you were like, "Huh?"
Mark Manson: I would say actually the biggest
thing, and this is kind of a broad thing, but
I think you and I are very similar in that
we started as online blog guys. And I think
when you come up in the internet world,
even if you amass a very large audience,
at least for me, there was always a
little bit of this chip on my shoulder of
I'm not a real writer. I don't have an article
in a magazine. There hasn't been a profile on
me in a newspaper. And there seemed to be kind
of an invisible wall between me and that world.
And so for a number of years I really, really
wanted that, for lack of a better term,
mainstream media attention. Just that nod
of respect of like, "Yeah, kid, you did it."
And when I started getting that and started
working and engaging with a lot of legacy media,
I was like, "Wow, this sucks. I miss my
blog. I miss the emails from my readers.
I don't want to do this. This is such
a pain in the ass." We have Zoom calls
with 11 people on them, and I don't know
who half the people are. So that's been
a pretty eye-opening thing the last few years.
Tim Ferriss: And to flesh out the current state,
most people listening will have heard
about Universal Pictures or have some
passing familiarity, "Oh, maybe I saw that at the
beginning of a movie, I think." Yes, you did. Not
a small entity. And I would love to know how this
feature film came to be. How did it come together?
And related to that, what does your current
team look like? Not only including any full-time
employees, but also agents, managers, et cetera.
Just what does that constellation look like?
Mark Manson: Well, the film, I
kind of Forrest Gumped my way into.
After the book blew up a bunch of studios
started sending offers to my agent and —
Tim Ferriss: For sure. To your book agent.
Mark Manson: Yes. To my book agent. And I
know you know this, but for everybody else, it's
pretty common for film and TV studios to buy up
rights to bestselling books without any intention
of actually doing anything with them. It's kind of
just like a land grab. Just in case, so-and-so
director one day is like, "I love that book.
I want to do a thing with it." They already own
it. So out of all these offers that came through,
there was some pretty off the wall stuff. There
was some stuff that I couldn't ever imagine myself
doing. And I told my agent, I said, "If we do
any of these deals, it's really important — the
only reason I think I'm ever going to do a film
or a movie or film or a TV show is to simply
spread these same ideas to people who don't read
books. To me, that's the only reason to do this."
So when the offer for a documentary came
through from a production company that
specializes in documentaries and has done
a bunch of them based on books before,
to me, it just seemed like a very logical fit.
I was like, "Okay, if I was to ever have a movie
that is the kind of project that I would do. I
would feel good about." My agent told me, she
said, "These things never get made. Don't get your
hopes up." I was like, "Okay, cool. I've never had
any ambition to have a movie or be in the movies."
So I was like, "Cool," kind of forgot about it.
Like a year and a half goes
by and I get a phone call
and it's the production company, and they're like,
"Guess what? We got financed by Universal." And
I was like, "Okay, what does that mean?" And
they're like, "You're going to have a movie,
you idiot. Do you want to be in it?" And I was
like, "Sure, why not?" And then from there,
next thing I know, I'm on a plane. I'm flying down
the New Zealand. I'm meeting with the production
company. I'm meeting with directors.
Tim Ferriss: Was New Zealand due to
COVID? Is that why it was in New Zealand?
Mark Manson: Yes, it was. The production
company is actually based in New Zealand, but
we were originally going to do it in New York.
But then when COVID happened, I used it also as an
opportunity to just get the hell away from COVID.
So during this whole process, they're telling me,
"We're going to have a theatrical release. We're
going to take it to festivals. We're going to do
this. We're going to do that." And I don't know,
and I'm sure we're going to talk about Will
later, but maybe from being around Will, I just
became jaded of Hollywood people. I was just like,
"Yeah, sure," while not really believing it. And
sure enough, we're a month out and it's
coming out, and it's going to have a
limited theatrical release. It's
going to be available online.
And I seem to be the one who's like, "Wait,
this is actually happening." It's one of those
projects that I can't take a ton of credit
for consciously navigating myself into. I
don't have the three bullet points of how
to get your movie made. I wish I did, but —
Tim Ferriss: Step one, have an
unexpected global bestseller.
Mark Manson: Yes. Step one, sell 10 million books.
Tim Ferriss: Step two, wait for a lot of inbound.
Mark Manson: Not very reproducible.
In terms of your question about team,
so I have my agent at CAA and she's phenomenal.
She's amazing. And the amazing thing about
her being at CAA is that it opens up all
these crossover opportunities into film,
into TV. It's how I ended up doing Will's book,
or a big part of why I ended up doing Will's book.
So she's great. I have my web team,
which is four full-time people.
I have a researcher. I have a content guy.
That is his official title, content guy,
because he just wears a lot of hats and he kind
of makes everything run. I have a tech developer,
tech/development guy, and then I have a social
media manager and it's all in-house. Everything
we do is in-house. All the design, the tech
stuff, the promotion, the marketing, everything.
We use a few freelancers, if we're doing
video content, stuff like that. But,
yeah, that's the team right now.
Tim Ferriss: Number of follow-up
questions on this, the web team,
you said four full-time people.
Mark Manson: Yep.
Tim Ferriss: Now is that including
the researcher, content guy, tech, and social?
Or is that in addition to, so you end up having
seven or eight full-time folks?
Mark Manson: No, those are the
four positions that are full-time.
Tim Ferriss: I see. I see. Got
it. Got it. What does the researcher
do? I mean, I know they do research,
but what type of research?
Mark Manson: So I don't have a
graduate degree in psychology, yet, I consistently
find myself in the sticky situation of having to
say something that feels somewhat authoritative. I
mean, I'm sure you're in this position a lot too.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, sure.
Mark Manson: At a certain
point I just went out and hired people with
graduate degrees in psychology, and said,
"Look, can you just make sure I'm not putting my
foot in my mouth or giving terrible advice?" So a
lot of times I'll go to her and I'll say,
"I've been thinking about an article on,
say, the negative side effects of self-esteem. Can
you go out there, find all the research and data,
what are the studies? Are they
good studies? Were they done well?
And then just summarize it for me." And then
if I want to dig into it with her, I can.
She's been invaluable. It's almost
like outsourcing a piece of my
brain to somebody. And it's been very helpful.
Tim Ferriss: And I'm asking about the team
out of personal curiosity of course,
but also because I enjoy and benefit
from hearing how people think about teams.
For instance, I'll give you an example,
Kevin Kelly, arguably the most
interesting man in the world,
people should look him up, kk.org. Also,
the author of a famous article called
"1,000 True Fans," which I encourage
everybody to read. And he said to me once,
explained to me rather that he has an assistant
and then he has a researcher, but they're not
the same person. And he said in his experience
very often to optimize for one or the other,
you will find that they are somewhat
mutually exclusive. In other words,
the traits are somewhat mutually exclusive.
Now, I don't know if I agree or disagree with
that, but it was an interesting observation based
on the pattern recognition from someone I respect.
So how did you choose full-time versus
contractor? Or internal versus external
would be another way to put it, I suppose.
Mark Manson: Some of this is personal
preference. I like working long-term with
people. I like finding exceptional talent,
paying them very well, and then sticking with
them over a long period of time. So I've never
had an employee leave. And two of my guys, one's
been with me for 10 years, one's been with me for
almost nine, and then the other two have been with
me for about three or four, which in the web world
is crazy. That's like crazy talk.
Tim Ferriss: It's eternity.
Mark Manson: And I have entrepreneur friends
with online businesses and they look at me
and they're like, "Are you nuts? You could
pay these people half as much." I'm like,
"Yeah, but I'd be hiring every six months."
Tim Ferriss: It'd be a Faustian bargain. Yeah,
you'd be paying for it with your time, for sure.
Mark Manson: Exactly. And I also just,
there's something to be said with the trust
and loyalty. I don't know how you measure that,
but there's the trust and loyalty that comes
with working with somebody for 10 years. So
two days before we're recording this, we
completely redesigned my site and relaunched
my newsletter. It was a multi-month project, and
I know the guys that I have, I know I don't have
to look over their shoulder. I know they're going
to get it done. I know it's going to be well done.
And a lot of that is simply because
I've been with them for so long and
they've been with me for so long.
Tim Ferriss: I feel the same way,
which is why I have full-time team. In addition to
contractors, I do use freelancers and contractors.
How did you find the members of your team? And we
don't necessarily have to go one by one, but do
you have a particular approach to sourcing talent?
Mark Manson: Yes. So I always find them through my
email list and my subscribers. I've tried through
kind of conventional job searching venues, and
you get so much extra leverage from, I guess,
the fan relationship. Generally, every time I
ask for applications through my own audience,
the people who apply are almost comically
overqualified and the talent level is through
the roof. And a lot of that is just, they love
my work, they've been reading it for years,
and that earns you a lot of clout.
Tim Ferriss: It does. That makes sense. And do you
mail out a link to a page with a job
description? Do you just simply put
it at the end of one of your newsletters.
You're like, "Hey, by the way, I'm looking
for this." Is it dedicated? How do you do it?
Mark Manson: So I will create a temporary page
for the position. I usually go through three
steps. So I have the initial application,
it asks for the generic stuff, resume,
cover letter. I'll usually ask a few cute
questions in there. What are your three favorite
books? What was the last risk that you took,
major risk you took in your life, and
what happened? Things like that. Although,
as the years have gone on, I'm discovering that
those questions aren't really great filters.
So I'll do that. That's kind of the first round.
I'll get hundreds and hundreds of applications,
and then I narrow it down to say 20 to 30 people.
Tim Ferriss: Do you review all of those yourself?
Mark Manson: So sometimes I will have a team
member kind of go through and just be anything —
Tim Ferriss: Putting highlights.
Mark Manson: Yeah. Or anything that
doesn't — because I'll set standards on the
application page. So I'll tell them, "Anything
that doesn't meet the application standards just
kick out." So this most recent round of hire,
I'm hiring a video team to start doing more video
content, and I asked for at least three years of
professional full-time experience in some form
of whether it's TV, film, YouTube, whatever.
And sure enough, you get 200 applications from
people who have never held a camera before,
but they're really ready to learn. They can't wait
to learn, Tim. So it's nice to have somebody to
just go and mark those all red for me.
Tim Ferriss: They want a scholarship
ride to graduate school at Manson University.
Mark Manson: Exactly. Exactly. So I'll filter
those down to 20 to 30 strong candidates,
people who meet the requirements and seem
smart and talented and driven.
And then I'll actually give them
a few small pieces of work to do, like, example
tasks similar to what the position is hiring for.
And I'll give them a deadline to meet it at.
And it's always funny, because there's always
at least two or three people who immediately
complain about this. And they say, "This is slave
labor. You're taking advantage of us. You're
using us to crowdsource ideas for yourself."
Which is silly, because, I mean, I understand
why they think that, but I think anybody who is
in our industry understands that ideas
aren't the thing that matter. And so
from that, I'll narrow it down to three to
five people, and then those people I'll do
face-to-face Zoom interviews, until I find
the one that feels like the right fit.
Tim Ferriss: What are you
looking for in the interviews?
Mark Manson: So by the time they get to the
interview, it is, they've basically shown
that they are completely qualified to do the
work. They're probably going to do a great job.
The interviews for me, it's 99 percent looking for
intangibles, looking for personality, character.
I usually try to get a sense of what their values
are, get a sense of how resilient they are.
Do they take responsibility for themselves?
A little bit about their background,
things like that. But also just like, do I get
along with them? Do I like talking to them?
Do we have a sense of humor that meshes well?
Things like that.
Tim Ferriss: Makes sense. Last question on
the team. And there's a point to all this, people
listening, part of which is just satisfying my own
interest, big part of which. But CAA, this agent,
there are a lot of agents and you've got quite a
few three letter acronyms to choose from, right?
You've got CAA, WME, UTA, and there are many other
boutique agencies and so on. A lot of people out
there who could ostensibly probably do a pretty
good job. Many who would promise the moon and
do a terrible job. But how specifically did you
decide on this agent that you work with at CAA?
Mark Manson: That's actually a great question.
So my blog blew up in 2013, 2014. It kind of
went from maybe a hundred thousand readers
to a million, million and a half. And around
that time, agents and publishers started coming
knocking, asking if I wanted to turn some of
my work into a book. And at that time, again,
homegrown internet guy. I self-published my first
book. I've been selling online courses since 2010.
I've always had a little bit of an
irrational, I want to do it myself
mentality. But back then I had a very, very
irrational, I want to do it myself mentality.
So a lot of my calls with these editors and
agents was basically me just being a bit of a
dick and being like, "Why should I publish a book
at all? Why shouldn't I just self-publish. I get
way more royalties or whatever?" And it was funny,
because pretty much everybody in the publishing
industry kind of stumbled over that question.
They couldn't really give me a satisfying answer.
So my agent, her name's Mollie, at the time,
she wasn't at CAA, she was at a small boutique
agency in New York. So I get on the phone
with her and we start having a conversation,
and she's constantly interrupting me, she's
constantly talking over me. She's very aggressive
and assertive, and to the point that I'm getting
a little bit uncomfortable talking to her. And
so I throw out my gotcha question, "Why should I
even publish a book at all? I can self-publish a
book and keep all the royalties for myself?" And
she kind of sat there silently, and she was like,
"Well, figure out what the hell you want
to do. Stop wasting my time. Call me if
you want to publish a book," and hung up on me.
And I was like, "Goddamn, all right." And a couple
hours go by and I start thinking to myself, I'm
like, "That's who I want bargaining on my behalf.
If I have a six or seven figure negotiation with
somebody, I want her on my team." So I called
her back and I said, "I'm in." And she's a total
rockstar in her field. And it was, again, Forrest
Gump moment. So right before Subtle Art came out,
she called me and she said, "Hey, I just want to
let you know I'm moving to a new agency. Nothing's
going to change. I'm going over to CAA." And I
was like, "Oh, cool, what's CAA?" And she kind of
thought I was joking, I guess, she didn't answer
me. And I remember, I googled CAA and if you go to
their website, it just has a snail mail address.
There's literally nothing on their website.
Tim Ferriss: There's nothing. Yeah. So for folks
wondering if they don't know, it's Creative
Artists Agency, it's one of the largest,
suppose we could call it, talent agencies
in the world. They represent a lot of the —
Mark Manson: Everybody.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, top tier,
A grade celebrities you would recognize.
Mark Manson: And it was maybe a week later,
I was talking to my editor and he
goes, "Hey, congrats." And I was like,
"For what?" And he goes, "Mollie's
moving to CAA." I was like, "Yeah,
why are you telling me congrats?" And he just
looked at me like I was the biggest fucking idiot.
He's like, "Manson, you just won the lottery."
Tim Ferriss: Well, speaking of winning the
lottery, let's talk about, and this is going
to be a bit of a strained metaphor, but
putting yourself in a position where at least
you have a chance at winning the lottery. And
I'm going to further confuse matters by reading a
paragraph from a Wikipedia entry on a video game,
and this will hopefully make some
sense for people in a second.
There's a video game called, and I don't know how
it's pronounced in English actually, but Katamari
Damacy in English, but in Japanese, it's Katamari
Damashii, which literally means clump spirit.
And the reason I learned about this video game was
in a presentation by Matt Cutts, who at the time
was at Google and he was giving a presentation,
I think it was at the State of the Word,
or an annual WordPress meetup. I could be
getting those specifics wrong, but I was there.
And he described how he observed
people building audiences over time.
This is where we're going to go through the
looking glass and go back in time with your
story. But here's the plot, this is directly
from Wikipedia. “The game’s plot concerns
a diminutive prince.” I'm not saying you're a
diminutive prince. “The game’s plot concerns a
diminutive prince on a mission to rebuild the
stars, constellations, and moon, which were
inadvertently destroyed by his father, the King of
All Cosmos. This is achieved by rolling a magical,
highly adhesive ball called a katamari around
various locations, collecting increasingly
larger objects, this is the key part, ranging from
thumbtacks to human beings to mountains, until the
ball has grown large enough to become a star,”
goes on and on. So that's Katamari Damashii,
at least in Japanese, I suspect they changed the
spelling D-A-M-A-C-Y, so they could trademark
it. But that's a side note.
All right, Matt's point was,
when you first start, you are generally, in these
success stories he has seen, starting very small
with a ball that's rolling up thumbtacks, and
then eventually it gets a little bit bigger
and you move to larger objects, and then you get
to humans, then you get to mountains and so on.
And I thought maybe we could start, if you're
open to it with you telling the backstory on a
character, maybe not a character, a person named
Entropy. Could you explain who Entropy is or was?
Mark Manson: Oh, my God.
Tim Ferriss: And then walk us
through the development, because it seems to
parallel this video game. In actually a very
similar way that my trajectory has
mirrored this video game in a sense,
the metaphor at least. So Entropy, who is Entropy?
Mark Manson: Oh, God. Well, ironically enough, it
was originally my gaming handle when I was in high
school, but it was my, I guess, you could call
it a pseudonym of my first blog. I started
blogging, my roommate had a blog in college,
and he and I, the pickup artist thing was
popular at the time, and so there was a
lot of kind of writing, like, "Oh, I went on a
date last weekend, this is what happened." And
him and another friend of mine were kind of always
egging me to, "Start a blog, dude. Start a blog."
And it was really just because we all read each
other's stories and stuff, and they wanted to read
mine. So that's actually how it first started,
was just my roommate peer pressuring me into
sharing stupid drunk things I did, as a —
Tim Ferriss: And what year is this roughly?
Mark Manson: This was 2007.
Tim Ferriss: 2007. Okay.
Mark Manson: — I was 23, and doing things at
23-year-olds do. And again, Forrest Gumping my
way into it, at that stage, there was no ambition
or kind of vision for this. It's just the cool
thing that my friends want me to do. And I enjoyed
it too, I found. That was kind of actually the
first point in my life that I discovered, "Hey,
it's really fun to sit down and write something
just because you enjoy it, not because it's a
term paper or whatever." So that went on for
about a year and I don't think the "readership"
was probably never more than a dozen people. But
then something strange started happening, which
is, people that I had never met started reading
it and commenting on it, and I have no idea how
these people found me or where they came from.
And that was a little bit mind blowing to me.
And it was around that time I started to get very
curious — so this also coincides, I was out just
out of school, the Great Recession was going on,
so there were no jobs anywhere. I was
basically living on a friend's couch.
And it kind of opened up this idea of,
"Hey, there's internet stuff you can
do. This blogging thing is actually a thing.
You can promote products and get commissions,
you can put ads on your site. You can make a
little bit of chump change, if you think about
it and are strategic about it." And this story's
going to lead to you, Tim, I got to warn you.
Tim Ferriss: Uh-oh. Uh-oh.
Mark Manson: So I started getting
curious about, I guess, you would call it kind of
the online marketing, online blogging world. And
it was around that time I discovered The 4-Hour
Workweek. I think it had just come out or been
out for a year or something.
Tim Ferriss: That was April
2007 it came out. Seems like a lifetime ago.
Mark Manson: I found that and I read it. So
to your credit, I read that book and it blew open
my mind in terms of what the possibilities were.
I was just like, "Oh, my God, you could do all
sorts of shit online and automate this stuff. Oh,
my God, I'm going to be living in Argentina
and this is going to be great." I'm like,
"Sign me up, dude. Here, I'll go buy..."
Tim Ferriss: Argentina, here I come.
Mark Manson: Exactly. I had a very love-hate
experience with that book, but in hindsight,
both were good. The love side of it was — it
just opened my mind to so many possibilities.
The hate side of it was, I thought it was going
to be so much easier. The way you described some
of those examples, I'm like, "Oh, yes, this was a
month tops." Meanwhile, a year and a half later,
I'm still grinding 12 hours a day. I went
through a period of, "God damn that Tim Ferriss,
what the hell was I thinking?" You and
I have had a complicated relationship,
you're not aware of most of it, but —
Tim Ferriss: Oh, tell me.
Mark Manson: No, I mean, it was a
difficult but very, very rewarding
period in terms of just trying all
these different websites, blogs,
SEO pages, and AdSense pages, and 90 percent of
it doesn't work. Then, the 10 percent that works,
it brings in $100 a month and you're like,
"Okay, well if I can just do 10 more of those,
maybe that gets me somewhere." It's one of
those grinds that you look back with some
nostalgia and romance — there's a little
bit of romance to it. I don't think I'd
ever be able to stomach it today, but as a
broke 25-year-old, I'm really proud of it.
Tim Ferriss: What was the website,
or the primary websites at the time?
Mark Manson: Oh, man. Back then, Google was
rewarding blogs. The idea was you build up a blog,
you create a bunch of articles about whatever
the topic is, you get a little bit of traffic,
and then you either put ads or do affiliate links.
I had a blog for Feng Shui, I had a blog for teeth
whitening strategies, I had a blog for — God,
I'm trying to remember, mixology and bartending.
Keep in mind half the stuff I didn't actually
know anything about, I just Googled other stuff
and rewrote it. It was not the greatest work
I've ever done, but in a way, it was putting in
the hours. Meanwhile, I had the Entropy blog,
which was still writing about my dating life.
Ironically, I guess I had to learn this
the hard way, that was the thing that
actually caught traction because it was
the thing that I actually cared about and
I actually thought about a lot from my day-to-day.
Tim Ferriss: Probably also enjoyed writing about
more so than teeth whitening and Feng Shui.
Mark Manson: Yes, 100 times more.
Tim Ferriss: Not to knock either one of those.
Mark Manson: Going to get a lot of
dentist hate mail coming to you.
Tim Ferriss: I don't want to miff the teeth
whitening young-adult novel writers out there.
Mark Manson: That's what started to take off.
I kind of found myself — in college, I dabbled in
the pickup artist stuff. As my blog started to get
accepted in those circles, guys started asking
me to coach them, they wanted to do calls, they
wanted to meet up with me, they wanted to bring
me down to New York and go out to bars with me.
As a guy with nothing else going on, that
was really enticing, it was really exciting.
I kind of got sucked into that world for
about, I'd say a year, a year and a half,
and then was pretty strongly turned off by
it. It felt very — obviously there was a lot
of toxic advice in that industry, but also just
the dynamics of everything was so performative.
Nobody actually really cared if you were having
a good time or not, nobody cared if the woman
you met was really smart or interesting or
funny. It was just like, "Did you make out
with her? Did you get her phone number? No. All
right, you're not on the scoreboard tonight."
That was kind of the extent of their thinking,
and so I started to become pretty grossed out
by it. But also at the same time, I realized
that there was very much an opportunity to
integrate some of those more healthy emotional
elements into it. I rebranded my website,
my little blog as Practical Pickup. I started
using my real name. I started promoting honesty,
vulnerability, actually giving a shit about who
you're talking to instead of just trying to press
the right buttons to get her into bed. I guess you
would say that was another — that's when that ball
started picking up bigger and bigger items.
Tim Ferriss: Started broadening the scope.
Let me ask you, this just popped into my head,
and I'll give a confession first. If I go back
and look at the oldest versions of my blog over
time, they're awful. Some of them are really,
really hard on the eyes, and that is not what
I'm going to say about my question coming right
now. But I'm curious, am I making this up
that on one of your blogs in the early days,
there's a photo of you with a very low cut
V-neck shirt on it? Am I making that up? It
just popped into my head. Is that a real thing?
Mark Manson: I had a goofy picture of me with
a scarf and sunglasses. Tim, you're
bringing out — this is the douchey
25-year-old Mark you're pulling out here.
Tim Ferriss: No, I'm not — I want to clarify
my intentions here. I want to clarify my
intentions. My intention is to show how
this ball works in practice, to use the video
game analogy, in the same way that I started
with very narrow — at least in the blog capacity,
I started a very narrow tech audience focused
productivity slot. That's where
I focused. Really, I was speaking
almost directly to people in Silicon Valley
where I lived at the time. It was very, very
narrow. Then, it expanded, and after the success
of the first book, I realized I didn't want to
get painted into the corner of being the X hour
work week guy forever, but I had the optionality
at that point, which might not come again to
try something totally different because I knew
publishers would take the gamble just based on the
audience that I built, so I did The 4-Hour Body,
and then it started to expand from there.
I want to
perhaps provide a little bit of historical context
also for the time that we're discussing. In 2005,
I want to say, The Game by Neil Strauss came
out, somewhere around there. Then, I want to
say it was in that same range, 2005, 2006 that I
Hope They Serve Beer in Hell came out by Tucker
Max. No matter what people feel about the content
in those books and the subject matter covered,
both of those got a lot of young men, or let's
say boys on the verge of becoming me, late
adolescence, writing for the first time. Then,
both authors, Tucker Max and Neil Strauss, ended
up doing their own version of rolling this ball
afterwards. My intention here is to point out,
in a sense, how much went into contributing
to where you are today, not saying you would
replicate it if you attempted to in the same way.
But that's why I'm going through this backstory,
because also — I'm sort of showing the punchline
in a sense, and I'd be interested to know if you
think this is a fair comment.
A lot of folks, especially I think
right now when they're able to study or at least
see supposed case studies of people becoming these
overnight successes on platforms like TikTok and
so on, they dramatically overestimate what they
are capable of doing in three months, but they
dramatically underestimate what they would be
capable of doing in three years, let's say. That's
why we're having this conversation in part because
a lot of folks are like, "Oh, Mark Manson, that's
The Subtle Art of Not Giving a Fuck guy. Oh,
my God, huge mega bestseller. I'm so glad that
he did that, and what a genius." You may very
well be a genius, but I want to provide the
backstory to the genius, if that makes sense.
Mark Manson: For sure. There's 10 years of quiet
iteration behind that big breakthrough success.
Tim Ferriss: Going from $100 a month with teeth
whitening and Feng Shui to writing a book with
Will Smith, that's a dramatic transition, but it's
not a one-step phase shift, right? It's this sort
of incremental build, and that's the picture that
I'm trying to paint. When did you go from then the
pickup expanded into honesty,
vulnerability, and then bleeding
into relationships to broader advice?
Mark Manson: The transitions
happened — the pickup stuff
kind of started 2009, I'd say,
the honesty, vulnerability stuff the next
year, 2010. Then, what I realized I think in
either late 2012 or early 2013, something really
strange happened, which is I realized that
25, 30 percent of my audience was female, which
is bizarre because I'm explicitly writing men's
dating advice and it is written in a way that
it's dudes in a locker room talking to each other.
But I kept getting emails from women
saying, "I don't relate to this or that,
but this advice you gave about boundaries is
the best thing I've ever heard. It's better
than any female advice that I've ever seen." I
started getting email after email of that. It
occurred to me that it no longer made sense
to limit myself to simply writing for men.
I took that step, the further step
of just rebranding to just my name,
I'm going to write for everybody, and initially
it was mostly dating and relationship advice. But
the other thing I started to notice around that
time as well — by then I had been writing, dating,
and relationship stuff for five years, and when
you really dig down into it, there's no such
thing as a dating problem. Every dating problem
is simply a personal emotional/trauma/baggage
problem that's manifesting as a dating problem.
Tim Ferriss: For sure. It's a human problem.
Mark Manson: It's just a human problem. I was
like, "I don't really think it's valuable for
me to sit here and write things like top five
first date locations," whatever. I should be
talking about this deeper level stuff because
that is what everybody seems to be struggling
with. That was also part of the transition
of getting into I guess what you would call
more traditional personal development topics.
Tim Ferriss: If we then flash forward, so we
have this blurry Austin Powers kind of transition,
and we end up, I believe — tell me if I'm getting
this right, January 8th, 2015. I may be getting
this right. Blog post, 2,354 words, I believe,
so this is the big one. This is
the mother lode. My question is,
before the blog post became The Subtle Art of
Not Giving a Fuck, what other names did you
consider for that, if you even remember? And/or
how did you just end up with the title? Because
you think a lot about wordsmithing and crafting,
I know you spent time on this, and I know you have
spent a lot of time thinking about headlines and
titles. What was the process of getting to that?
Mark Manson: There's not really a way to answer
that without going back a little bit and talking
about what that era of social media was
and what my whole process was back then.
I think I had my first mega
viral post in 2012, early 2013.
It took a while for everybody to figure out, but
it was right around then that Facebook turned on
the spigot of reach for outside published
material. Facebook decided that they wanted
to be the newspaper for everybody, and so if you
were able to write an attention-grabbing headline,
a little bit of copy, have an intriguing image,
you would just go crazy on that platform.
The big growth spurt that happened in my audience
was on Facebook from 2013 to 2015. Subtle Art was
actually one of the last viral articles I had in a
series of probably eight or 10 very viral articles
over that two-year period. I discovered this
and then started refining a process, and as you
pointed out, a huge part of the process was title.
I just realized the title is almost as important
as the entire article itself, so I
started spending hours just writing out
dozens and dozens of titles. I also just
kept around title ideas that I had. I just
had a Google Doc that I'd be out at dinner with
a friend, he'd make a joke, and I'm like, "That'd
be a really good article title," and I'd pull
out my phone and jot it down on the Google Doc.
The Subtle Art, the title had been sitting on that
Google Doc for a while. I'm a big metal fan, and
the band, Lamb of God, has a song called
"The Subtle Arts of Murder and Persuasion."
It was right around that time — I forget, I
had a couple articles with — another thing
about Facebook's algorithm at the time, I
noticed that if I just put Fuck in the title,
you would get 50 percent more juice.
Tim Ferriss: Turbo Boost.
Mark Manson: Yes, exactly. It was like a cheat
code for Facebook. I was looking for — my mind
was already in a spot where I'm looking —
Tim Ferriss: Back in the wholesome, good ol’
days. The F word, oh, my God.
Mark
Manson: I was already existing in a head-space
where I'm always on a lookout for a clever use
of the F word. I was listening, I was a huge
fan of Lamb of God, and that song comes on my
iPhone or whatever, "The Subtle Arts of
Murder and Persuasion," and I was like,
"The Subtle Art of Not Giving a Fuck."
I was like, "Wow, that's really catchy."
Then, it sat on the document for a while, and then
it's actually funny how the article got written.
It sat there for many months, I never really felt
the inspiration to do something with it. Then,
there was a period that holiday, the Christmas
and New Year's right before that — as you said,
it came out January 8th, that holiday
was really shitty for a variety of
personal reasons. It was just one of those
Christmas holidays that you're like, "Fuck,
why do I have a family? Do I have
to spend time with these people?"
I was coming out of that in a pretty bummed-out
state. My wife, who I was not engaged to yet at
the time, there was Visa trouble so she was
stuck in Brazil. I was actually in Austin,
I was sitting alone and basically just moping
in Austin for a few weeks. When I get mopey,
I get very, very snarky and bitingly sarcastic.
It was time to write an article, and I pull up
the list and I see that title and I'm like, "You
know what? I am going to write the most offensive,
profane thing I can possibly imagine, but I'm
also going to give the best possible advice that I
imagine I can give. I'm going to combine the
two things, and I just want to create that
dissonance in people." I wrote it and I thought
it was completely over the top and ridiculous.
Sometimes when you write something, I'm sure you
have this experience, you can't really tell if
it's good or not, you're too close to it.
Tim Ferriss: Yes, you're too close to it.
Mark Manson: I put it away, I woke up the next
day, I was still unsure about it, and I sent it to
my content guy, official title, who also kind of
acts as an editor for me. I told him, I was like,
"I don't even know if I want to post this, it's
pretty ridiculous." He came back on Slack in all
caps and he was like, "You can fire me, I'm
posting this fucking thing." He's like, "This
is the best thing. We have to post this." Sure
enough, he was right. It went absolutely crazy,
it was everywhere.
Tim Ferriss: Yes, I remember that.
I do remember that. The banner with the kitten
thinking, all that. I remember seeing that when
it came out, and I was like, "That's a really,
really good headline." It was a good piece too.
But I remember thinking, "Man." Every once in a
while, it could be an album, it could be — this
harkens back to my early days when I had the
sports nutrition company and was doing now what
would be called D2C, but lots of paid advertising,
so I needed headlines to work. I was also working
with very expensive long-lead publications
like magazines. Good Lord, you think it's
hard to zig-and-zag online, man, with that type
of lag time, it's brutal. I developed an affection
for really, really good titles and headlines. I
was like, "Man, that's a gold medal right there."
Out of curiosity, of the eight or so articles
that you had go mega viral in a two-year period,
which especially in the context of that time,
is a very high hit rate. I mean, thinking back
to that time, I was on the playing field, that's
a very high hit rate. How many of those started
with a headline and then became an article,
because I would imagine most people who write,
write something and then try to come
up with the headline? Oftentimes I
think that will be the case.
Mark Manson: I would say half,
it was probably 50/50.
Tim Ferriss: What was second
place in terms of virality, do you remember?
Mark Manson: Second place was "Seven Strange
Questions That Help You Find Your Life
Purpose." Then, the number one question was,
"What is Your Favorite Flavor of Shit
Sandwich, and Does it Have an Olive?"
Tim Ferriss: Oh, the questions, the questions.
Things go completely cuckoo bananas. Watching it
from, I suppose I was saying the sidelines, but
kind of front row seats because I was tracking
things in the blogosphere, roughly speaking,
quite closely because I was still so involved.
Mark Manson: We're in the same
space, we have mutual friends.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, yeah. How many blog posts
have you written? Do you have any idea?
Mark Manson: Well, I think the site still houses
about 250, but a lot of them have been removed.
Tim Ferriss: Decommissioned.
Mark Manson: Decommissioned. Thank you for
your service, you are no longer necessary. I would
say probably in the neighborhood of five, 600.
Tim Ferriss: That's a solid — I
mean that's solid canon. After,
let's see, a thousand plus on my blog, because I
got started in 2005, so I had a bit more of a lead
time, I ended up spending a lot of time thinking
about the crafting of certainly pieces and also
headlines. Before we delve into the explosion
after that event, and I think a lot of people
might be able to fill in some of the gaps because
they, I would imagine at least more than a handful
of folks, will have some familiarity with maybe
the later chapters of what the success of that
book looks like, and seeing the orange cover
everywhere, any airport anywhere in the world,
there it is. I actually do want to ask
about the cover because that's I think an
element that has also worked tremendously well.
But before we get to that, what are the things
that you most struggle with now, or recently?
Mark Manson: This is going to be a bit of a
blasé answer, especially probably for you
and your audience. I have always struggled
with the physical health side of things. I spent
pretty much all of my twenties getting my head
in order, getting my baggage cleaned out, fixing
my relationships, understanding my emotions,
developing self-awareness, all these
things. I was always so focused on that,
that I never really developed good habits
around taking care of myself. I'm at that
point now in my late thirties where you actually
pay for those bad habits, because when you're 28
you don't really pay for it, but these days — I
hit a point a year or two ago where I realized
it's never going to get easier or better. It's
not a sexy answer, it's kind of a blah answer,
but the last year especially has been
very, very health focused. I've actually
been listening to a shit load of your episodes
on subjects like that. It's been very helpful.
Tim Ferriss: I appreciate that. The
health piece, this is — I'm 45 now, and
all of those little decisions add up. I've
been pretty good at maintenance, but I've also,
just through pure life aggression, sustained
30-plus fractures, a handful of surgeries,
and holy shit do those start to reappear.
The degree of self-care, what I've realized,
just needs to go up in a very non-linear fashion
the older you get, or you just start sliding in
a really significant way. I'm in maybe a similar
boat in the sense that I'm also, in the last year
and certainly for this upcoming year, going to be
focusing on the health component because it's this
upstream variable that just affects positively or
negatively everything else. For what it's worth,
I'm happy to chat about that anytime.
Mark Manson: Thanks, man, I appreciate that.
Tim Ferriss: Whenever I feel like I'm getting off
the rails, it's just, for what it's worth, I have
found — I have some degenerative disc issues in my
back also, which is unfortunate, but congenital–
Kettlebell swings, slow carb diet, perhaps
also skipping one or two meals, let's just say
breakfast because I find that easier than portion
control, and some type of core work, whether it's
something like really technical Pilates or
let's just say gymnastic strength training also,
but that's a bit more aggressive on
the joints so you have to have that
stability/connective tissue strength. But if I
just do core work, kettlebell swings, pushups,
and some type of diet that restricts high
caloric density, carbohydrates to some extent,
it really makes a huge difference. Do you
have pains? Do you have a lot of pains?
In terms of symptoms, is that...?
Mark Manson: I actually don't,
I'm very fortunate in that regard. I just
got fat. Especially, I mean we're going to
get to my run the last five years and
all the projects I did, I overworked,
I overdid it. The wake-up call for me was actually
— I was writing three books at the same time.
Tim Ferriss: Sorry.
Mark Manson: You know how stupid that is.
I was writing three books at the same time. I
was living in New York, traveling, I'm on planes
if not every week, every other week. I was
actually sitting in my office one morning and
I started having intense heart pain, or chest pain
I should say. I started having intense chest pain,
and it freaked me out. I have a history of
heart disease in my family and I was like, "I'm
fucking 37, this can't be happening." I sat down,
went to a doctor, ran all the tests, everything's
fine. But he looked at me, he's like, "Have you
had any stress going on in your work lately?"
But yes, I had gained probably 25,
30 pounds. The little exercise I
had been doing before then went out the
window, my eating habits were terrible,
my sleeping habits were terrible, I
had massive circles under my eyes.
I kind of had just this come to Jesus moment
of like, "Dude, you can't put this off any
longer. You have to do something to take
care of it." There was also a little bit of
a humbling that had to happen of realizing that
after a number of years of trying to do it myself,
that I just — for whatever reason, this
part of my life, I don't seem to have good
decision control, so I hired a
coach and that was super helpful.
Speaking of that snowball effect, the further I
go down the path, the more I want to go down the
path. I also feel a little bit stupid because my
whole thing for 15 years now has been all about
how people think, feel, and helping them deal
with struggles and pain in their life better, and
I'm sitting here and I'm like, "Wow, not drinking
for a few weeks, going to bed at 10:00 PM, I feel
20 percent better on a day-to-day basis. How did
I not realize this before?" How am I so late to
this party? It's been an interesting experience.
Tim Ferriss: Just out of curiosity, where were
you when you stopped drinking and started going
to bed earlier, getting a solid night's sleep,
just geographically, where were you?
Mark Manson: L.A.
Tim Ferriss: L.A. I ask, because New York,
in my experience — I grew up on Long Island,
I've spent a ton of time in New York
City. It is just a cultural norm
I mean to drink four or five nights a
week, and you get on this caffeine/booze
seesaw, which is the norm for millions
of people every week, if not every
day. That's why I was asking about the switch.
Mark Manson: I was completely unprepared for how
influential moving from New York to L.A. would be
in that factory, because you're absolutely right,
all social life in New York revolves
around eating and drinking alcohol, and
after seven years it adds up. It
really adds up. Whereas in L.A.,
people don't drink nearly as much. Everybody wants
to go on a hike, they want to surf, they want to
go hang out on the beach. So, it's been very good.
Tim Ferriss: The where of health matters a lot,
not just the how of health. The how of
health is often a consequence of the where,
in a way. L.A. does have that in
spades. If you haven't been to
the Venice Boardwalk green on, I want to say
a Sunday when the acrobats go to train, you
should definitely check that out. You see Cirque
du Soleil athletes practicing on this green,
which is probably 30 by 30 feet, and —
Mark Manson: That's awesome.
Tim Ferriss: — if you just want a casual pass
by a Cirque du Soleil performance, you can
take a look at that. It's inspiring. It's really,
really inspiring. Let's talk about the five-year
period of projects and the three
books at once. Oh, my God. Oh, boy,
that's a lot. Could you describe what you did with
Will Smith, how it came to be, and your personal
primary lessons learned? It doesn't
have to be from the content of the book,
it could also be from the interactions, exposure
to L.A., entertainment, et cetera. Just love
to know what you did, for people who don't
know, how it happened; maybe those are in the
opposite order. And then what your personal
primary lessons learned were from that.
Mark Manson: I co-authored Will Smith's memoir,
which came out last year. It's called Will.
We worked on it for I think about two and a
half years together. The way it came about
was his team actually reached out to me. He
had wanted to do a book for a little while.
I wasn't there, but from what I understand, he had
some casual meetings with a few different authors
just to see what was out there, and when
they contacted me about it, first of all,
another story of my agent being great. My agent
didn't tell me about it right away. The first
thing she did is she sent me an email and she
said, "Hypothetical question. If a celebrity
wanted to write a book with you, on what terms
would you be interested?" Which is smart,
because she didn't tell me who it was.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, that's smart.
Mark Manson: And I said, "It would have to be
an A-lister, and they would have to want it to
be more than just about their life. They would
want to dig into their problems and history and
baggage, et cetera." Which is, as it so
happens, exactly what Will wanted to do.
After that, we set up the meeting. Super
surreal. I always tell people the craziest part
about meeting a really, really famous person
isn't actually the really, really famous person,
it's all the shit that goes on around the
super-famous person. It's hard to explain.
But next thing I know, I'm getting whisked away
to Atlanta, where I'm supposed to meet him on set
of a film that he's working on. Turns out
Ang Lee is directing that film. So, I'm like,
"Don't fanboy at Ang Lee, don't fanboy at Will
Smith," like, "Oh, God, this is so stressful."
And you're supposed to just act casual, like this
is all normal. So, he finishes, they're rehearsing
a scene or something, and I'm walking in circles,
not knowing where you're supposed to go, and
his people are like, "Are you okay?"
And I'm like, "Where should I sit?
I've never been on a Hollywood set before."
Tim Ferriss: "What do I with my hands? What
do I do with my hands?" Like Ricky Bobby.
Mark Manson: I told one of his managers,
"I've never been on a Hollywood set
before. I don't know if I'm in the
right place or not," and she just looked at
me like, "Really?" And I was like, "Sorry."
Next thing I know, they finish rehearsing.
We go straight to an airstrip, I'm getting
loaded onto a private jet, and they're like, "No,
no, no, you need to sit in the front with Will,
because you're going to talk about the book
now." And I'm like, "Now? Okay." First time
on a jet. So, we're being whisked away. The
whole thing is just surreal and strange,
and everywhere he goes there's a mob of
fans waiting for him, people shrieking.
It took a few days to get over that, get in a room
with him privately where it's quiet, and actually
have an extended one-on-one conversation with him.
Before I went to meet him, I had two conditions
for myself. The first one is,
he can't be an asshole, because
no amount of money, no amount of prestige is worth
spending three years working with an asshole.
And then two was, everything needs to be
on the table. He needs to be very willing
to open up and go anywhere. We had a few
really good, productive conversations,
and I was blown away. The thing that
really knocked my socks off about him
is, he's a smart guy, obviously, he's
a very hard-working guy, obviously.
His charisma and his ability to read a room and
react in a way that makes people feel comfortable,
and then also talking to him a little bit about
some of the hurdles that he went through in
his life, his ability to adapt to setback, to
reframe it in a way that is helpful to himself,
it's really incredible. I know this seems
strange to say after the Oscars incident,
but he really is one of the most emotionally
intelligent people that I've been around.
We had a dinner the last night, and he just out
of the blue was like, "What's up, Mark? Are we
going to do a book or what?" And I was like,
"Well, I've got an outline in mind," and I
told him the thing I just said about
emotions and his ability to use his
emotions to adapt to things. I also said it's
probably why he's such a good actor, is that
he's able to summon emotions and play with
them and react to them in a masterful way.
And I said, "I think the book should be built
around emotion. It starts with fear. It moves
through all your defense mechanisms into
your fame, into all the success, until
that facade collapsing, and it eventually,
finally ends up at love, at a very genuine,
authentic love," which is something
that it took him a long time to get to.
And I said, "As you move through all those
emotions, there's a word for somebody who's
able to move through setbacks and deal with
any sort of negative emotion and harness it
to advantage them. It's Will. So
that should be the name of the book."
It was like the Fresh Prince came back. He was
just like, "Hell, yeah." He gets up, starts
slamming stuff on the table. He's like, "Hell,
yeah. Hell, yeah, we're doing that." And I'm like,
"All right. I got the gig?" But it was a —
Tim Ferriss: Good meeting, good meeting.
Mark Manson: Yeah, a good meeting, good meeting.
But it was a wild and fun two years with him.
As you can imagine, I get so many questions
since March about him, but honestly he's such a
great guy deep down. Obviously, he makes mistakes
and does stupid things like the rest of us. But
I have nothing but gratitude for that project.
It was very easy to write, it was very enjoyable.
The way we did was, I presented the outline, we
refined it together. I wrote the first draft,
he did a revision of that, and then me and
the editor at Penguin did a final pass.
So, it really is both of us in that book.
A lot of people assume it was all me,
or assume it was all him, I don't know. But it
really was both of us. He put a lot of work and
effort into it, and he really cared about it.
Tim Ferriss: I'm going to ask about what
you learned about Hollywood and entertainment
through the process of interacting with him and
writing the book. I'll just open a door
if you want to walk through it; if not,
we can skip it. I know you just mentioned
a lot of people have asked you about the
Oscars and Chris Rock incident and so on. Is
there anything you want to say about that,
or about him with respect to that, or
not? You can also just say, "Nope, not
really," and we can move on. Totally up to you.
Mark Manson: I publicly wrote a piece about it
as a newsletter. It's on my website. The TLDR of
it is basically he did something really stupid
and unacceptable, but as somebody who spent
a lot of time around him, and not just him:
his family, his friends, getting to know
his kids, getting to know his brother,
honestly, there is so much generosity that happens
with him that nobody ever sees, and it's very much
by design. He doesn't feel a need to publicize
it. Just seeing what I've seen being around him,
I told people, "Look, that's not
the real him. That's the worst
side of him. The Will that you
know and that you hope is real,
that's the real Will. He's a very
great, loving, but flawed human being."
In terms of what I learned, and you asked earlier
what I learned from him, it's funny, because he
does have a marvelous story of resilience and
overcoming. He comes from a very dysfunctional
family: an abusive father, grew up on the
streets of West Philly, very rough neighborhoods.
It's actually very remarkable how he navigated
that and avoided all the pitfalls that come
with that sort of upbringing to get where he
is today. It's definitely not an accident.
That story is amazing, but there
were no epiphanies for me personally.
The epiphanies for me personally were
just being around him as a professional;
being around a guy like that who's been at the
top of his game, top of his field for 30 years,
one of the most famous human beings on
the planet. I was blown away at the way he
worked with his team, the way he was with
his fans, the way he dealt with the media.
To be honest, dude, the first time I hung out
with him and I saw him get mobbed by fans,
my immediate reaction was like, "Man, I should
be nicer to my fans." I think Will is nicer to
his fans than I am, and he's Will Smith.
Tim Ferriss: He's paddling out through
100-foot waves every time he steps out of a door.
Mark Manson: But one of the things that he helped
me see, and he said this to me too, is he was
like, "I'm very aware that every encounter I have
with a fan is a very asymmetric encounter. For me,
it's five seconds that I'm going to forget about
within a minute. For them, it's five seconds
they're going to remember for the rest of
their lives." So he's like, "Just put in the
effort for those five seconds. The payoff
is so monumental for the other person that
there's no ethical argument to not do it."
The other thing that he said that was really
profound for me, because as you can imagine, he's
got this full staff of people that just follow
him around the world; he's got cooks and chefs and
wardrobe people and security
guys and everything, logistics.
I asked him once, "Do you ever feel like it's
weird just having this team of people that just
shadow you everywhere you go?" I was like,
"When was the last time you cooked a meal
for yourself?" He started laughing and he's like,
"I don't know, man, probably at least 10 years."
But he told me, "Look, it's really
simple. I am world-class at one thing,
and it'd be very easy for me to be the humble guy
and cook a meal for myself and send the chef home,
but I'm only world-class at one thing, and that
would take away from my time and energy from
being world-class at that one thing. Not only
that, but my chef is world-class at one thing,
and by sending him home, I am taking
away from his ability to be world-class
at the thing that he's world-class at."
Tim Ferriss: That's cool. I saw potentially the
first part coming, but not the second part. That's
a significant addition, looking through the mirror
from the other direction, not just your direction.
Mark Manson: He described it as robbing him of an
opportunity to be excellent, which just
to me is such a beautiful — it's funny,
because you hear so many outsourcing conversations
in terms of business of how to hire and outsource
and automate and do all this stuff. He
spoke about it in ethical terms, which
was really profound for me.
Tim Ferriss:
What did you observe, or what stood out
to you about how he worked with his team
outside of that example that you just gave?
Mark Manson: This validates what we were
talking about earlier. The first thing
that really stood out to me about his team
was they've all been with him forever. It
was funny, he's got one guy named Scotty,
who I love. Scotty has been in a few of
his YouTube videos; lovely, lovely guy.
Scotty was joking with me. He's like, "I'm the new
guy on the team. I've only been here nine years."
Everybody in significant roles in his
team have been with him since at least
the Fresh Prince days, many of them since
the '80s, some of them since he was a kid.
They're childhood friends that he
put into the appropriate place.
That really blew me away. It also validated
a lot of my beliefs around loyalty and
trust. He also explained it to me once
as, "Look, when you become famous,
nothing is scarce. If you want money, you
can go get money. If you want parties,
you can go get parties. If you want sex, you
can go get sex. The one thing that becomes
more scarce as you become famous is trust." So he
said, "I very much tried to build my organization
to optimize for trust first and everything
else second," which I thought was very wise
of him. But in terms of just operationally,
he's very good at including everybody.
There's no rigid hierarchy of, "Well, you're the
assistant of this manager, so you shouldn't be in
the room talking about these ideas." He loves
to just joke and bounce creative ideas around,
and if it's the lowly production assistant
who comes back with a great idea, he's happy
with that. He'll run with it. He doesn't feel a
possessiveness around who gets to tell him what.
Tim Ferriss: Fascinating.
Super, super fascinating.
What are your goals, desires, wants maybe? I don't
know how crazy we want to get. But in the next,
you can choose the timeframe, three years
— because there was a point, as you said,
you're writing for your friends
in college, readership per se of
no more than a dozen people, not really thinking
about where this is going or how you're going to
optimize it. It was just writing, having fun with
friends and enjoying the process. Now you have,
among other things, paradox of choice situation
on your hands, where there's more inbound than
you can probably even begin to process, even
more than your agent can probably process.
She has to have some quick means of eliminating
things. How are you thinking about what you want
to do or not do over the next handful of years?
Mark Manson: The place I'm in now, I will write
more books, but I'm in this almost prodigal son
coming back to the internet moment. Doing all of
these projects over the last five years in legacy
media, it's been very rewarding, and it's been
in many cases very fun and educational.
But what I realized is that that's not
what I love doing. I love just the raw dynamism
of posting something, getting immediate feedback,
processing that feedback, understanding, "Oh,
people like that. Why did people like that?
What is it about that idea that resonates with
people?" And then trying to figure out, "Well,
how could I do something more with that?" I
love that process so much, and the immediacy
and the creative control that comes with that,
that I'm envisioning this place in my career as
I'm coming back to that. I mentioned earlier
that I'm currently hiring out a video team,
and before 500 people listening to
this start sending me applications —
Tim Ferriss: I can learn. I can learn, Mark.
I'm willing to work for free, but you have
to teach me everything.
Mark Manson: Exactly.
I've already made the initial hires. If there
are more people that I'm hiring, subscribe to
my newsletter. It'll be announced there. I'm very
bullish on online media and independent media in
general, and I think it has a bright future.
You can argue it's already the predominant
form of media in terms of just where
the narratives come from and where the
best content comes from. But I think
that's only going to continue over the
next decade. So, I'm excited to be here for that.
There's two things that I love. One is what I just
said, the immediacy of online content. The other
one is I have this very, very strong passion,
bordering on fury of a thousand suns, to take
the self-help world, which traditionally — when
I was growing up, when you were growing up,
self-help was not something for the masses.
If you had a bunch of money in your savings and
could fly to a city and sit in a conference room
for five days, that's where this content used to
be. I think over the past 20 years we're living
through, I don't know if "democratizing" is the
right word, but just a widespread dissemination
of these very important concepts and ideas to the
masses for either free or very, very, very cheap.
I really deeply believe that
a lot of these concepts,
these basic things that you and
I talk about week in, week out,
they should be everywhere. They should be taught
in school. Basic relationship skills should be
taught in school. Basic meditation, a lot of
the exercises you do in therapy, CBT, these
concepts should be taught everywhere. Everybody
should have access to them all the time. I'm very
passionate about that idea, and that has always
been kind of a chip on my shoulder that I've had
throughout my career, and it's still there.
There's still work to do. So, the marriage of
those two things is where my head is at right now.
Tim Ferriss: To choose the things you want to do,
which you've been describing, to home in on the
things that you know you enjoy. It would seem to
me that a prerequisite of ensuring that happens
— I have a number of follow-up questions, this is
one — ensuring that happens requires you say no to
a lot of stuff that you either ignore completely,
don't respond to, or say no to a lot of stuff.
You're fortunate that you have a team, so Mollie
can also say no to a lot of things on your behalf.
I'm curious how you're thinking about saying no
to very tempting things. And they may not be
tempting, but I'll give you an example. You get
an email from Mollie, she's like, "Might be worth
a five-minute conversation; give me a call." You
get on the phone, she's like, "Steven Spielberg.
He read Will, he's not done this for anybody,
he wants you to write a three-part —
Mark Manson: Oh, God.
Tim Ferriss: — book series."
Mark Manson: People can't see, but
I'm already facepalming!.
Tim Ferriss: And maybe I'm actually screwing up
this thought exercise by making it a three-parter.
It's not a three-parter, but it is going to be
a year or two of focus on this, which would be
the seminal, definitive book with Spielberg's
full cooperation, full access, journals,
everything. Pay you some insane amount of money,
twice the number that you would pick as a stretch
goal that you're like, "They'll never say yes to,"
he's like, "I'll just pay you twice as much. Let's
get this over with so we can get to the work."
What do you do when stuff like that comes
up? Because you know it's going to come up.
Mark Manson: Well, I don't know if that —
Tim Ferriss: Maybe not that specifically.
I'm using an absurd goal to drive the
exercise, because if it's like, "Eh,
this is a B-minus offer," easy to say no to,
because you want to strive to do an A-plus
in the things you just described. How do you think
about, say no to the stuff that will be tempting?
Mark Manson: Well, for lower-level stuff. I
think the best way is to simply set rules.
I've done that with speaking the last year or two.
Tim Ferriss: What are your rules?
Mark Manson: My rules are
basically it either needs to be
an Uber away, or it needs to be just
an absolutely stupid amount of money,
which nobody takes the stupid amount of money.
So, it's basically just an Uber away. Also,
I decided too that I'm not really going to
do keynotes anymore. If you want me to sit
onstage and answer questions, that's fine, but the
preparation, the thought, the practice that goes
into a keynote, the mental energy, that sucks.
Tim Ferriss: You're not getting paid for 60
minutes on stage.
Mark Manson: No.
Tim Ferriss: You can pay for everything around it.
Mark Manson: Exactly, exactly. So, speaking has
been a big one that I've cut out, and actually,
the delta between how speaking opportunities
look on paper versus reality, it's just so wide,
because you get that email and then there's this
number with a bunch of zeros behind it and you're
like, "Oh, my god, that's the easiest money ever."
Then you actually go do it and you're like,
"Wow, I just spent a week not doing anything
else to be here." So, rules around that.
To the Spielberg opportunity, my rule with
any celebrity memoir would probably
be very similar to my rule with Will:
A-lister, has to be doing it for the
right reasons. I think the difference
this time would be, part of the reason I
gave myself chest pains a few years ago was
I think I was so eager to say yes to things.
To back up a little bit, after Subtle Art,
there was a little bit of this insecurity, maybe
call it impostor syndrome, of like, "This might
be my 15 minutes. Say yes to everything,
because who knows if this is going to come —
Tim Ferriss: Who knows? Totally.
Mark Manson: — back around." So, I did that. I
don't necessarily regret it, but I think this time
around it would be on my terms. It would be like,
"Is he an A-lister?" Yes, he is. "Is he doing
it for the right reasons?" I'd probably have to
sit down and talk to him, get a feel for
that. "Is it a good fit chemistry-wise?"
I'd have to sit down, figure that out. Then
I think it would be on my terms. I'd be like,
"Here's my schedule for the next two years.
Here's where I can fit this in. This is when I'm
available. Take it or leave it." I think the money
at this point would be a very, very minor factor.
I've definitely hit a —
Tim Ferriss: Only so many Skittles you can eat.
Mark Manson: Seriously. You do hit
a certain number where you're like,
"Fuck it, I'm just going to do stuff I
want to do." Very fortunate to be there.
Tim Ferriss: Let's say Monsieur Spielberg,
he's like, "Great, that all sounds fantastic."
Would it fit around what you just described
you would want to do, or would it start to
crowd it out, just knowing yourself?
Mark Manson: If that offer came down
the pipeline tomorrow, my reaction would be, "I'm
building out a video team. We're going to start
scaling video content in 2023. I'm under another
contract with Harper to do another book in 2024,
so we can get started 2025 if you want."
That would probably be the conversation,
which I'm sure he would hate. The challenge
there would be holding a line with that,
if he started to push back and it's like, "Well,
we'll offer you twice as much money as your
Harper contract." You can't get seduced.
It's like boundaries in relationships. If
you tell somebody, "Hey, this doesn't work
for me, don't do it," and then they do it,
it's really hard to not let it slide. Nobody
wants to confront people in their lives and say,
"Hey, that's upsetting to me. I told you not
to do it. It's really hurtful that you did
that." Nobody wants to have that conversation.
But if you want to have good relationships,
you have to have that conversation. I think it's
the same in the professional world. If you don't
set those boundaries of like, "This is what works
for me," and if you don't hold those boundaries,
then you just end up in this no-man's land.
Tim Ferriss: Furthermore, if you don't
hold those boundaries, if you make exceptions,
those exceptions are going to travel. Then people
will either say, "You don't actually follow your
own rules, so you should say yes to my," fill
in the blank. And most certainly, because I've
experienced this and I've become a lot better at
holding strong lines in the last, say, 10 years,
people will get pissed. People will get very
pissed. If you've said no to a bunch and then you
say yes to one because for whatever reason it's
more appealing or it just bleeds over into the
"maybe I should let this slide" category, you can
really find yourself in just a world of messiness,
slogging through the swamp of unclear boundaries.
Mark Manson: It's funny too, because
early in my career I prided myself on my ability
to say no to things that I didn't want to do.
That was kind of a badge of honor I had. What I
didn't realize is that as you scale the mountain,
the things you have to say no to are
proportionally difficult to say no to
as how high you get. So, it's a skill you have
to keep learning over and over and over again.
Tim Ferriss: It absolutely is. The stuff you're
saying no to now, flash back not that long ago, a
handful of years, they would have been offers that
would have exceeded your wildest dreams, right?
Mark Manson: Yep.
Tim Ferriss: And these
are the things you have to say no to now. It's a
funhouse mirror of psycho-emotional experience,
because it's not like we've let go of all of our
conditioning and hard-wiring we've developed over
decades. It just doesn't happen overnight.
Let me fulfill a promise to my audience,
because I did say I was going to
ask about it: The Subtle Art cover.
What is the background story on the cover,
and how do you feel about it? Did you like it
when you first saw what ended up being the cover?
Mark Manson: I love the cover. To Harper's credit,
they did it.
Tim Ferriss: Good for them.
Mark Manson: It's funny, because when I
went into that book, that was my first
book with a publisher, all my friends who are
published authors had all these warnings of
how horrible publishers are and how terrible
decisions they make and all this stuff, and
everything with Subtle Art was just a breeze.
Everything went really well, everybody got along,
there were no problems, and I was like,
"Wow, what's everybody talking about?"
Tim Ferriss: That's amazing. I will just
highlight, this is extremely rare. I'm not
a therapist, I don't play one of the internet,
or I try not to, but was just doing my 100th
iteration of a three-hour therapy session with
someone who's going through their first book
experience. I'm like, "I'm sorry. I don't know
what to tell you, I'm sorry. This is the norm."
Because he was like, "Is this normal? This
can't be normal. Does this is actually happen
all the time?" And I was like, "Yep, it does."
Mark Manson: It's actually obnoxious. If you
get any amount of authors in a room together,
inevitably the conversation just always ends
up in bitching about publishers. The funny thing
about the cover though, they were very adamant on
the orange. Initially, it didn't have that splat.
The splat was me. Again, this is credit to them
because I didn't realize this was not normal. They
sent the initial draft of the cover, I took it,
opened up Photoshop myself. I think I changed
the font to be the same font as my website,
and then I added the splat because I wanted
something kind of iconic to, I don't know, seem
fitting. I sent it back to them and they were
like, "We love it. It's great. We'll do it."
I was like, "Wow, great. I love these guys."
Sure enough, you find out that that never
happens. The publisher never listens to your
feedback. They try to force things through.
But it's actually ironic because I think at the
time I was just this no name internet guy and so
they're like, "Oh, yeah, well if that makes
him happy, let's just put it on the cover,"
but then once you become Mark Manson or
Tim Ferriss or Ryan Holiday, suddenly —
Tim Ferriss: Once they've got the sunk cost of a
real advance, now things are a little different.
Mark Manson: Exactly. It's like everything is
just murdered by committee over and over again.
Tim Ferriss: What excites you these days? I'll
give you two options. This is a multiple choice.
What excites you these days? I think in part
you've certainly answered or alluded to that,
and with video and the teams. I think this is
maybe me as an avid horse buggy driver in a
world where a model T came out a few years ago
and everybody's moving to cars and I'm still
digging my horses, trying to sell people on why
my horses are so incredible, but is the drive to
video something that you really want to do in your
heart of hearts or, and this is not a pejorative
option B, is it because inevitably everything
is driving to video and that if you're not
capitalizing on that, you are simply going to
be invisible to the algorithms that matter and
the results that matter? Or something else?
Mark Manson: It's a great question and I'm
not going to lie. There's definitely some of the
latter in it of just like, "I love this business,
I love what I do, and blogs are dead." You and I
both know blogs are dead. You get no reach for any
sort of written content whatsoever. Newsletters
are getting super saturated. It's hard to
stay in front of eyeballs in our industry.
That said, I had a little bit of a — I wrestled
with this past year because I think it's been
like four years now, my team has been telling me,
"Dude, you either need to do videos or have
a podcast. Dude, you either need to have
videos or have a podcast."
I'm like, "Motherfuckers,
I'm writing three books right now. Talk to me in
two years." But they were right and I knew they
were right. It's just the way the world is going.
I actually dabbled a little bit with a podcast. It
was funny. I went, actually, I think you have
an old article from years and years ago about
the starter kit of equipment.
Tim Ferriss: Yep. Mm-hmm.
Mark Manson: Bought all that stuff and I just
wanted to do a dry run just to see, do I enjoy
this? Is it fun for me? Actually, my first
guinea pig was our mutual friend Ryan Holiday,
so I went over to his house down there in Austin,
brought all the mics and everything, sat down,
talked to him for an hour and a half, two hours,
went home, opened up the audio, started listening
to it, and I realized that it was probably
the least interesting conversation Ryan and I
had ever had in our five year friendship. That
immediately gave me a respect for what you do
and other podcasters do. Because on the outside it
looks like, "Oh, yeah, you just sit down and talk
to somebody. How hard is that?" You don't realize
how much goes into being a good interviewer,
how much thought you have to
put into the questions you ask.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I usually
have this out of frame. Yeah.
Mark Manson: Yeah, yeah. It's not
an accident. It's not an accident.
I realized that that was just something,
it definitely wasn't grabbing me.
On the video side of things, I initially did it
for the reason you just said. I was like, "Well,
having a YouTube channel just seems like
a thing you're supposed to have," and so
I started recording some short videos about two
years ago and sent it off to a freelance editor
and kind of never thought about it after
that. But as time went on, I started to
enjoy it more and more. I think the thing with
video is that there's a very long learning
curve to it. You have to understand it's not just
about being good on camera. You need to understand
lighting, you need to understand audio, you need
to understand editing, file types, resolutions,
aspect ratios, all this stuff, and usually
the way you learn is by fucking it up first.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. Also YouTube. You have to
pay attention to the headlines, the thumbnails,
a million other variables. there's a lot.
Mark Manson: Yeah. It's been a slow burn for me,
but I think it started to become the highlight of
whatever I was doing that month.
Tim Ferriss: Okay. This is interesting.
How did that shift happen? How
are you making it fun for you?
Mark Manson: Okay. I don't know if you run into
this much, but one of the frustrations I've
started running into is when it comes to personal
development topics, there's nothing new under the
sun. All of these concepts and ideas, save for
some recent psychological research or every
couple times a year, a really great news study
will come out in psychology, and then three years
later it's not replicated. Most of what we're
working with is ideas and concepts that have been
around for decades, if not centuries.
Tim Ferriss: Footnotes to Plato.
Mark Manson: Yeah, right? Exactly. Everything's a
footnote to Plato. There's only so many ways you
can write about how to get over anxiety before
you just start repeating yourself. There's only
so many ways you can write about getting over a
breakup before you just start repeating yourself.
The last few years I've felt like I've hit that
and it's been frustrating. You feel like you're
trying to reinvent the wheel all the time. I feel
like video — a new medium opens up opportunities
to approach age old topics from a new direction or
new dimension and that's kind of my plan for that.
I've become a lot more interested in, okay,
I'm less interested in writing about theory and
this is how your mind works and this
is why you get anxious and this is
what resilience is, and I'm becoming far
more interested in implementation. Okay,
how do you actually get somebody who's read
this stuff to go do something with their life?
If you're limited to the written form, you can't
really do anything about that but if you've got
a camera with you, fuck it. Go visit the guy,
see if he's getting off his couch, film it, ask
him how he's feeling. I think there's just a lot
of opportunity to explore things in that format
that haven't been tapped into. That's
what really excites me at the moment,
the new creative opportunities in that sense.
Tim Ferriss: It sounds like format wise,
at least at first blush as you're
describing it, it's not going to be
Between Two Ferns with Mark Manson. You won't be
sitting down, doing a video, what people might
think of as a video podcast necessarily.
Mark Manson: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: You'll probably be featured and a
part of the entire cocktail that makes it work,
but do you envision a lot of it being
case studies, so to speak? Or real world
tracking of different people in a sense?
I know tracking might be a strange word.
Mark Manson: I think there's a lot of, keep in
mind, this is still super early days for me,
but I've got a lot of brainstorms
around this right now. One idea that
I've talked to the team about is you can kind of
reinvent classic psych studies. There's a famous
marshmallow study. You could probably do a really
fun and entertaining version of that with just
random people off the street and give them 100
bucks if they win or whatever. I think there's
a lot of opportunity to do a real time — you can
use things as incentive, you can kind of gamify
it a little bit. I don't know if you've watched,
there's a new trend going on YouTube of gamifying
everything. Mr. Beast got huge and everybody's —
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I've seen Mr. Beast, for sure.
Mark Manson: Yeah. When I was watching Mr.
Beast, the thing that occurred to me was,
"Okay, well that's fun. You put people in a
circle and see how long they can stay and then
give them $100,000," whatever amount he gives
them. What if you actually took somebody who's
struggled to lose weight over the last five years
and you're like, "Hey, I'll give you $50,000 if
you lose 20 pounds in the next six months," or
whatever, and then you track them and follow
them and see what's their process, where do they
get hung up? What are the self-defeating beliefs
and doubts and stuff like that? I think what
I like about it too, is that if you look at
research on motivation and people actually
sticking to behaviors and goals and things like
that, money is one of the most effective inputs.
Tim Ferriss: Super effective. People don't like
to hear it, but man, do incentives work.
Mark Manson: What's that Charlie Munger
quote? It's like, "Everything is incentive..."
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, just follow the incentives.
Mark Manson: Yeah, just follow the incentives. But
yeah, it works. It's not scalable on a mass — you
can't have an army of therapists who offer
you $1,000 to lose weight, but you can have
an asshole on YouTube who does, and I'll be that
asshole. That's kind of like the working concept
at the moment. I think it'll be fun, but it also
just — it renews the subjects for me. I've been
beating these dead horses for 15 years at this
point and this brings the horse back to life.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Mark Manson: I think
it also just introduces a lot of these concepts
and ideas to a new generation. Gen Z is not on
Twitter, they're not reading blogs, they're not
signing up for newsletters, they're on YouTube,
they're on TikTok, so that excites me as well.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I dig it. I love that you're
tweaking and brainstorming to keep it fun and
interesting for yourself. I've seen so many
examples of YouTubers who have created a style,
very successful style. They've been cursed with
getting a lot of attention and ultimately a lot of
money for creating a caricature of themselves that
they then have to continue to be.
Mark Manson: Yep.
Tim Ferriss: The question therefore
of how do you do this in a way that is
energy giving, fun, creatively satisfying on
some level without just being the Nth person to
come up with a 22nd dance routine on TikTok,
hoping that you're going to ride that wave?
Mark Manson: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: If that's not something in a
million years you would ever want to do otherwise.
Mark Manson: Yeah, I feel like I have a couple
competitive advantages. Entering
that space in a serious way,
I feel like I have a couple of competitive
advantages for the simple fact that I'm old
because most big YouTubers, they're 20 something
year old dudes who have never had a real job,
never been married, don't have kids. I feel like
as somebody who has been doing this for a long
time and who has fallen into a lot of those
traps of feeling like you have to please the
audience all the time, or feeling like you have
to publish all the time or being terrified that
you're going to lose people or they're going
to leave you or whatever. I've gone through
that in my own way and I feel like I've got my
head on straight about it at this point. Then
I also just think it's an advantage to be older
and know who you are. Be in a position where it's
like — well, it's like the Spielberg thing, right?
It's like, "Well dude, I got enough Skittles.
Thanks, but I don't need your views. Thank you."
Tim Ferriss:
Yeah. You also are in the enviable
position of having the ability to do
a huge range of experiments because you have sort
of the time and space if you choose to create it
and protect it, you have resources, so if you
wanted to do something out there that might
cost a pretty penny, but you can afford to lose
it, you can do that. It's a great position to be
in. I'm excited for you. Couple of boring tactical
questions. Do you still use Scrivener when working
on your books, or do you use other workflow?
Mark Manson: I used Scrivener for the first
draft of my first two books or for Subtle Art and
for Everything's Fucked. I find it great if you
still haven't quite nailed down the organization
of a book. Scrivener is great for moving around
large chunks of text very —
Tim Ferriss: Totally.
Mark Manson: — easily, but its actual user
interface I think is inferior to Word so
if you're actually trying to go line by line
and just make everything really polished and
clear, I think Word. Usually I would do
first draft on Scrivener and then import
it over to Word and do all my revisions on Word.
Tim Ferriss: And go from there. Sophie's World.
I have read, I don't know if you still feel this
way, this is from an interview on nomadicmatt.com
from a while back, and it has here, you can't
believe everything you read on the internet,
so feel free to confirm, deny, or modify, but,
"If you're a complete newbie to philosophy and
want to get a basic understanding of the Western
canon I recommend a book called Sophie's World by
Jostein Gaarder, I want to say? It's a fun fiction
book that acts as a kind of primer, or primer,
depending on how fancy you want to get
to the most important Western thinkers."
Is that still a book you would recommend?
Mark Manson: Yes, with the asterisk that I
read it as a teenager and it is a fun way to
get, I would say, a Wikipedia understanding
of each major thinker and their contributions
and how they influenced Western civilization.
Tim Ferriss: Which writers or thinkers or — let's
stick with writers first, and we can then talk
about other people who might be influencing your
thinking, but are there any particular writers
or books that you have been paying particular
attention to in recent memory? I can buy some
time by giving examples.
Mark Manson: Okay.
Tim Ferriss: I would say there
are the long-standing influences,
which we don't necessarily have to focus on, but
we could if they're still highly relevant to you
in your life now. For instance, I believe
that you've mentioned David Foster Wallace,
Joan Didion, Hunter S. Thompson, and
others, Steven Pinker, Jonathan Haidt.
In my particular case, for instance, I've had a
number of books recommended to me only one of the
three of which I've read. That would be, I believe
it's Four Thousand Weeks by Oliver Burkeman,
which I thought was a fantastic book and
there are a number of chapters that really
stuck out as counterintuitively helpful, such as
cosmic insignificance therapy, which I ended up
excerpting on the blog because I wanted to share
it with people and share the book with people.
Then there's another, which I suspect I will
find interesting, which is called Die With Zero,
which is by, I believe Bill Perkins. I have
not read it yet, but these are books that seem
to cohere in a puzzle of life philosophies
and instructions that I think will be very
relevant to me now and over the next, say, five
years, so I'm paying attention to those books
and the threads that appear to connect them.
I'm also paying attention because I'm working
on fiction right now in this highly absurd, but
very, very fun series of world building exercises
that I'm doing in fantasy, actually. It's very
different from anything I've ever done. If
people want to take a look, the project is called
CØCKPUNCH and you can find it online anywhere. Go
to Cockpunch.com, and I bought that URL.
Mark Manson: I tried to get on your
white list, but it was impossible.
Tim Ferriss: It was surprisingly
popular. There's a lot of demand, there's a
lot of fun coming. That is an example of me
doing something for the pure fucking joy of
it, and I'm having a lot of fun with that.
At the same time, I can study, say, Ursula K. Le
Guin and these classic, iconic, highly skilled
masters of the craft, whether that be fantasy
or science fiction. I'm paying attention to,
for instance, The Writer's Journey,
which is effectively The Hero's Journey,
adapted, but applied to writing.
Those are the examples personally
of things that are currently on my mind.
I've also realized that I've been over caffeinated
and inflicting biological anxiety on myself in a
very unnecessary way so I'm going to be revisiting
some of the Stoic writings, probably The Moral
Letters to Lucilius by Seneca, which is commonly
sold through, I think, Penguin classics as Letters
from a Stoic. That would be a very long word salad
of books of books that are currently on my mind.
Mark Manson: Gotcha.
Tim Ferriss: There's like one that's kind
of anchoring to two more I want to read,
and then with the craft that I'm currently
involved with, let's call that fiction,
a few things that tie into that.
Mark Manson: Yeah, okay. Yeah,
it's hard because when you just say —
there's so many books to talk about.
Tim Ferriss: There are a lot of
books. There are a lot of books.
Mark Manson: So many books. But yeah, I mean
you definitely hit what I would consider my
biggest influences. David Foster Wallace's
non-fiction is what made me want to be a writer.
Particularly his piece A Supposedly
Fun Thing I'll Never Do Again,
I go back and read it every couple years and
just in awe of how clever and observant he is.
Hunters S. Thompson, Joan Didion. I kind of
think there's almost like different categories
in my brain, so there's non-fiction writers I
appreciate for the quality of their writing, which
they are in. There is non-fiction, I would call it
academic non-fiction, which I mostly read just to
make sure I understand the prevalent research
in the space, which would be Jonathan Haidt. I'm
a huge fan of Dan Gilbert. He's got a great
book called Stumbling on Happiness, which —
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, excellent book.
Mark Manson: Yeah, in my opinion, it's kind of
the best book about happiness research and all the
paradoxes and contradictions that come with it.
Then in another category, I guess you
would call it contemporaries. I also
love Burkeman's book. I'm actually
friends with Oliver. He and I used
to be meditation buddies in New York.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, no kidding. Small world.
Mark Manson: He sent me a draft of that for
a blurb and my email back to him was like,
"You fucker, man. Every once in a while you
read a book and you're a little bit angry
because you're like, 'I wish I wrote this,'
because it's that good and it's that smart."
I was like, "Yeah, this is that for me. I'm happy
for you, I'm so happy for you," but there's a
little piece of me that's like, "Shit."
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Mark Manson: It's great.
Tim Ferriss: It's very well written.
Mark Manson: Yeah, it's fantastic. Stuff that
you or Ryan or James Clear, people in this new
personal development space I'm always tracking.
In terms of just what I've been reading recently,
I've actually been reading a lot
of fiction the last year. I am not
going to start writing fiction unlike
you anytime soon. Maybe one day,
it's actually kind of a bucket list
thing to do a novel one day, but
it's funny. Again, coming out of this intense
period of work, it's almost like my brain just
seemed kind of repulsed by a lot of non-fiction.
Tim Ferriss: I like dark chocolate, but I've
had it five times a day for the last three
years. I need a break from dark chocolate.
Mark Manson: Seriously, man. I read, both in
terms of research and also just my own curiosity,
I read hundreds and hundreds of books, non-fiction
books over that period, and I think coming out of
it, as soon as I didn't feel like I had to read
those for a project anymore, my brain was like,
"All right, give me fantasy, give me fiction."
Tim Ferriss: No more homework. No more homework.
Mark Manson: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss:
What kind of fiction?
Mark Manson: I'm actually trying to get back to
lighter fiction.
Tim Ferriss: Mm-hmm.
Mark Manson: Stephen King is one of those
authors that obviously I've always heard of him,
always know about him. I read a couple
of his books in high school, loved them,
and then never really went back to him. Now that
I'm kind of on this decompression reading kick,
I've taken upon myself to go to actually go
back and read some of the Stephen King classics.
I read, this is not fiction, but it was
a biography. I read Unbroken by Laura
Hillenbrand about World War II, incredible
story. I've been reading a lot of World
War II stuff. All the Light You Cannot See
was fantastic. I'm on a light fiction kick,
just letting my brain —
Tim Ferriss: Recover.
Mark Manson: Yeah, and maybe it's also because
just creatively in a zone in my career that's
very open and creative right now and I want to
just be able to let any idea in and play with it,
so maybe that's why it feels right.
Tim Ferriss: I was thinking of
easy-to-read fiction than I've enjoyed in
the last few years. If you wanted to read,
especially if you never have read a hard boiled
detective fiction novel that I thought was
incredibly hilarious and came highly
recommended, The Last Good Kiss by James Crumley,
C-R-U-M-L-E-Y. Some of the language is dated, I'll
warn people in advance, so trigger warning, but
it is, as it says in its description on
Amazon, one of the most influential crime
novels ever written by a legend of the genre.
It's hilarious and the writing is very strong.
James Crumley, The Last Good Kiss —
Mark Manson: Last Good Kiss.
Tim Ferriss: — would be pretty high up. I'll
give you one other different genre just in
case you want to screw around. This is, well I'll
give you two. On the sci-fi side, either of the
anthologies by Ted Chiang, C-H-I-A-N-G.
Man, those are just incredibly strong.
Mark Manson: Unbelievable. Yeah, I read both of
his collections, I think I want to say three or
four years ago. Yeah. Just floored me. I was —
Tim Ferriss: So good.
Mark Manson: — speechless afterwards.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, incredible. Along those,
I don't want to say same lines because each
of his short stories is so different, but
there is a book called This Is How You Lose the
Time War and part of what makes it so cool is
that it was written by two people who alternated
chapters as they went along, but it is entirely
cohesive. How you even do that is almost beyond
comprehension. I can see how you could have
a writing partner and you work on a screenplay
together, but to write a super compelling sci-fi
novel that is a category breaking format
in and of itself, deeply sophisticated and
time-bending with two authors is something
else. It's a fast read, super compelling.
Anyway, I'll throw that one out just as an option
if amongst the 100 other books you're reading,
you're looking for a hundred and first.
Mark Manson: Nice.
Tim Ferriss: Well, Mark, this has been a
really fun conversation. We have covered a lot.
I don't feel the need to try to bleed the stone.
I think people will find at least a few stories,
a few tidbits, in this that
they can walk away with and
ponder or use in some fashion. Is there
anything else you'd like to say? Any
closing comments, questions, anything
you'd like to point my audience to?
Anything at all that you'd like to add?
Mark Manson: No, just the usual. Go to my
website, read my shit type thing. I do want to
say thank you to you. Seriously, you've been
a pioneer for my generation and been a big fan
for a long time. My adolescent anger towards you
aside, while I was sleeping on couches, seriously,
for those of us who are the generation under you,
you've been showing us how to do it for
a long time now so I appreciate that.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, thanks, man. I really appreciate
that. It's been really fun to see you on this
rocket ship and it's been very fun for me to
have this conversation also 'cause I've wondered
often. I'm like, "I wonder how the fuck he's
feeling about all this? What is his experience
like? I wonder what the experience might be to
be in his shoes right now?" It's been fun to
get a peek on the inside and to hear it straight
from the man himself. I really do appreciate it.
Everybody, you can find all of Mark at
markmanson.net. The new redesign is beautiful.
Mark Manson: Thank you.
Tim Ferriss: It's very elegant. It's
very clean. I've been thinking of doing a complete
redesign on my site for the first time in a long
time and went to your site just in the course
of doing research for this conversation, and I
was like, "Wow, that's clean. That's clean."
Mark Manson: Yeah. Yeah. The old design was like
eight years old and it was funny because as soon
as the first drafts of this new one came in, me
and my developer went and looked at the old site
and we were just horribly embarrassed. We were
like, "How have we allowed this to be online?"
Tim Ferriss: Onward and upward, you're trending
in the right direction. I look forward to
seeing the video, look forward to seeing
the film also. Keep an eye out, folks. That'll be
released in theaters by Universal Pictures. Wild.
Mark Manson: Crazy.
Tim Ferriss: Who would've thought?
My God, when back when you were working on teeth
whitening and feng shui. It's so fun. I find it so
inspirational to track those things from the
very early beginnings because you can't possibly,
if you had sat down, and maybe you did when
working on all those many sites and throwing
everything against the wall, and tried to
form a 10 year plan that would get you here,
it would've been impossible. Impossible.
Mark Manson: Never. Never.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. It just wouldn't have worked.
Mark Manson: But it's like the Steve Jobs thing
where you can connect the dots going back. I
look back and yeah, all those bullshit SEO sites,
I needed those to kind of build up the skillset
to actually build a functioning company and a
blog that got an audience. Then from there
you learn the skills to expand the audience
and like you said, it's the tacky ball.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, it's the tacky ball.
The [foreign language 02:14:08], the
clump spirit. Sounds better in Japanese.
Mark Manson: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Well, Mark, I really appreciate
the time. Thank you for taking it and being so
open to discussing all of the things. Really,
really do appreciate the time and appreciate
what you're trying to do in the world and what
you are doing in the world, so keep it up.
To everybody listening until next time,
one step at a time. Keep that sticky ball rolling
and don't underestimate what you can do over time.
Try not to overestimate what you can do in a
given week or month because you'll just end up
beating the shit out of yourself and that does
not tend to help you in the long term. Be just
a little bit kinder than is necessary to not just
others, but to yourself, and thanks for tuning in.